[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا كيف ترى ايران
والميليشيات المواليه لها اتفاق و في
اطلاق النار في سوريا وم الاته وصف وزير
الخارجيه الايراني محمد جواد ظريف الاتفاق
بانه انجاز كبير واشار مسؤولون روس الى ان
ايران وضعت في اجواء المفاوضات التي قادت
الى هذا الاتفاق كما انها ستشارك بفاعليه
في التحضير لمفاوضات استانا بين اطراف
النزاع السوري غير ان استمرار هجوم قوات
النظام السوري وحزب الله اللبناني على
منطقه وادي برده في ريف دمشق بعد سريان
اتفاق وقت اطلاق النار والحديث التركي عن
ضروره خروج الميليشيات المواليه لايران من
الاراضي السوريه طرح السؤال مجددا عن
التباينات الروسيه الايرانيه على الساحه
السوريه وتاثير ذلك على تماسك وقف اطلاق
النار الذي تضمنه
روسيا كانت تلك المش حتى الامس القريب
الاف المدنيين ازهقت ارواحهم على مدى 15
شهرا كانت الاشد الدمويه منذ بدء الثوره
السوريه كان عنوان تلك المرحله التدخل
العسكري الروسي المباشر غيرت العمليات
الروسيه موازين القوى العسكريه وخلطت جميع
الاوراق السياسيه وفي جميع الاتجاهات
لتصبح روسيا اللاعب المتفرد في الساحه
السوريه ومن يدير المشهد بينما ركن نظام
الاسد بصوره علنيه وحشر في الصفوف الخلفيه
راعي المشهد الدموي السوري بطائراتها
المقاتله والسفن الحربيه المدجج التي خلفت
وراءها بركا من الدماء تحولت بين عشيه
وضحاها الى راعيه سلام بل انها بدات تتصدر
المشهد السياسي ومساعي الحل
السلمي التفرد الروسي في مشهدي الحرب
والسلم لم ينظر له حلفاء موسكو بارتياح
وصاحبته ردود فعل معترضه وان كانت بصمت
وجد النظام السوري وحليفه الايراني
نفسيهما في موضع المنفذ لتوصي رو موقف
اعلان الاسد قبول الهدنه فورا اثر الاعلان
الروسي فضلا عما تلاه من اعلان ايراني
مماثل شكل المشهد الاكثر وضوحا على حاله
السمع والطاعه التي لم يجد الطرفان بدا من
القبول بها ولو على
مضد خلال شهور التدخل العسكري الروسي حاول
النظام الاسد الخروج عن عباءه راعيه في
محطات عده لكن الرد الروسي كان مباشرا وفي
مرات منها كان مذلا استدعاء الاسد الى
موسك وهو في موقف من يتلقى التعليمات من
قبل الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين ثم استدعائه
مره اخرى الى قاعده حميميم شكل ابرز
المؤشرات على ما تريد موسكو ان تبلغه
للاسد عن مكانته وحدوده على الطرف الاخر
كانت ايران التي عطلت حساباتها ورهاناتها
في المشهد السوري بعد تدخل روسيا الطرف
الثاني الذي حاول ان يسجل حضوره ويقدم
نفسه لاعبا اساسيا في الساحه السوريه لكنه
فشل في عده مراحل امام صد
رسم مسار اللعبه محاوله ميليشيات ايران لا
سما حزب الله تعطيل اتفاق حلب الاخير كانت
مثالا على الحدود التي وضعت لايران هددت
روسيا حينها بقصف اي مجموعه تعطل الاتفاق
وهو ما اذعن له حزب الله سريعا واعلن
مباشره قبول الاتفاق قدره روسيا التي
اثبتتها في الضغط على ايران وميليشياتها
وعلى نظام الاسد معا بعد ان فرضت نفسها
لاعبا متفردا في الساحه السوريه في زمني
الحرب والسلم تبقى العامل الاهم في انجاح
الاتفاق الاخير لوقف اطلاق النار الشامل
في عموم سوريا وفرض شروط الحل السياسي
مستقبلا وعلى
الجميع من اسطنبول ينضم الينا روسلان
قربانوف المحلل السياسي وكبير الباحثين في
معهد الدراسات الشرقيه ومعنا في الاستديو
الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي الخبيره في الشؤون
الايرانيه وابدا مع السيد روسلان قربانوف
من اسطنبول سيد قربانوف روسيا في هذه
الايام هل هي من
اي يحدد حجم المشاركه وحجم الدور الايراني
في المفاوضات وفي ايضا الازمه السوريه
وترسم هامش التحرك الايراني في هذا
الوقت كما تعلمون نستطيع الان ان نؤكد بان
هذه
السنه كانت سنه في غايه الاهميه بالنسبه
لروسيا لتثبت وتبين العالم كله الدور
المتزايد والنفوذ المتعاظم لروسيا وقد
اثبتت ذلك
وعرضته في الساحه ساحه المعركه السوريه
ولكن المشكله كانت هو ان الشريك الرئيسي
في روسيا عد النظام السوري كانت او دوله
ايران الشيعيه وفي هذه
[موسيقى]
الحاله فانه من المهم جدا بالنسبه لروسيا
ان تحصل
على دول شركاء من الدول
السنيه مثل حكومه تركيا ولذلك فحتى اعتقال
عفوا اختيال السفير الروسي في
انقره لم لم يؤثر ولم يؤدي الى قطع
العلاقات الوثيقه بين موسكو
وانقره
و
وبقبول
ودعوه قبول دعوه تركيا لعمليه سلام في
سوريا اثبتت روسيا للعالم السني والعالم
العربي والدول اخرى في العالم بانها اي
روسيا هي فوق التناقضات الطائفيه وضد او
ليست ضمن وال الانقسامات الموجوده في
المجتمع السوري بين العلوين والسنين
والشيعه وغيرهم والشيء الاخر الذي يجب
نذكره هو ان روسيا قد
ارسلت كتيبه من الشرطه العسكريه الى حلب
وذلك للحفاظ على الا الامن والنظام في
المدينه وفي روسيا جرت مناقشات وقول بان
الجزء الاكبر من هذه الكتيبه كانت من
المقاتلين تشيش
شانين و وهذه الحقيقه في غايه الاهميه
بالنسبه لروسيا لان الشيشان اعتذر هنا سيد
سيد قربانوف عذرا عذرا هنا للمقاطعه لانه
اريد ان ابقى في نقطه محدده وكانك تقول
بانه
نعم هناك يعني تراجع الى حد ما او تحجيم ل
الدور الايراني بما يمثل طائفيا ل صالح
دور تركي ربما ايضا بما يمثل طائفيا كانني
افهم ذلك منك ساعود الى هذه النقطه معك
بالتحديد لكن انتقل الى الكتوره فاطمه
انطلاقا مما سمعناه هل بالضروره التفاهم
الروسي التركي بشان الازمه السوريه
يعني تراجع لمستوى التفاهم الاستراتيجي
بين ايران وروسيا حول الواقع في سوريا حول
سوريا ليس بشكل كبير لكن بالتاكيد هذا
الاتفاق اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار جرى جزئيا
او الى حد كبير تهميش الدور الايراني يعني
اذا رصدنا ردود الفعل الايرانيه فهناك ما
يشبه الصمت الايراني تجاه الاتفاق ردود
افعال ايرانيه الى الان قليله حول الاتفاق
ما يشبه التجاهل داخل الصحافه الايرانيه
لهذا الاتفاق اليوم وكاله الانباء الرسميه
ايرنا كانت تتحدث عن تصريح لم يصدر عن
بوتين قالت ان بوتين قال ان روسيا وايران
وتركيا يضمنون تنفيذ الاتفاق في حين ان
هذا ان الضامنين هم روسيا وتركيا ايران
ويبدو ان ايران يعني قبلت على مضد هذا
الاتفاق وهذا له اسبابه
الكثيره يعني اذا رصدنا فقط التصريحات
الايرانيه قبل ايام قليله بعد معركه حلب
ال كل مجمل الاداء السياسي الايراني كان
يتجه باتجاه مغاير عن الحل
السياسي ويبدو ان يعني القابلين بالحل
السياسي داخل ايران هم يعني فئه قليله لكن
يعني الضغط الروسي للوصول الى حل سياسي
يبدو انه يعني دفع الايرانيين مرحليا
للقبول بهذه المساله طيب سيد
قربانوف ما هو دور ايران تحديدا في ما
يتعلق بالتفاهم الاخير بالاتفاق الاخير
اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار وا ايضا فيما يتعلق
بالوثائق التي
بدات تتسرب حاليا الوثائق ما بين تركيا
وروسيا حول الحل السياسي المرتقب والذي
بدايته من
استانا نعم هذه وثائق مهمه جدا لاننا نعلم
ان كان ثلاثه وثائق جرى توقيعها في نهايه
هذه المفاوضات الاول وثيقه كانت بين
النظام السوري
والمتمردون والثوار في سوريا والوثيقه
الثانيه حول الاجراءات الخاصه بطريقه
المحافظه على عمليه بناء السلام والوثيقه
الثالثه هي الاستعداد الاستعدادا
لاجراء المحادثات السياسيه في
استانا وان السيد بوتين قال انه في الوقت
الحالي تركيا
وروسيا
يدعوان كل الدول بشكل عام الى المجيء الى
مائده المفاوضات في استان مثل السعوديه
وقطر والاردن ومصر والعراق وما الى ذلك
واعتقد انهم اتخاذ هذه الخطوه فان موسكو
تريد ان تبين او تثبت انها بهذه الطريقه
بهذه الطريقه لتحقيق عمليه السلام هي
الطريقه المثلى والفعاله وهو ما تقدمه
للعالم روسيا وذلك ايضا
لاثبات ان الخبره السابقه في عمليه بناء
السلام في جروزني
وشان
هي ممكن الطري هي الطريقه الحده الممكنه
للتوصل الى تحقيق السلام في سوريا ولكنني
اخشى ان النزاع السوري اكثر تعقيدا بكثير
من النزاع الذي كان في شيشان وربما موسكو
ستواجه عددا كبيرا من المشاكل الخطيره
والتناقضات ما بين الاطراف المعنيه سيد
قربانوف مره جديده يعني لا ادري لماذا
تحجم عن الاجابه على السؤال السؤال
المتعلق بايران والعلاقه الروسيه
الايرانيه ودور ايران في كل هذه التطورات
وربما ايضا غياب مواقف ايرانيه
حقيقيه تشجع وترحب بهذا الاتفاق باستثناء
الكلمتين لوزير الخارجيه الايراني ساتوقف
الان مشاهدينا عند تصريح لوزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود شاووش اوجلو قال فيه ان
بلاده تامل في ان تمارس ايران نفو ايجابيا
على حزب الله والمنظمات الشيعيه والنظام
السوري من اجل تطبيق اتفاق وقف اطلاق
النار هذا جاء في مؤتمر صحفي لشويش اوجلو
في مدينه انطاليا جنوب تركيا
نتابع تم التوصل بالامس لاتفاق عام بين
الاطراف لنشر الهدنه على كامل المناطق
السوريه تركيا دوله ضامنه للهدنه في سوريا
فهي تضمن الوثيقه التي وقعت عليها
المعارضه السوريه المسلحه الموجوده في
تركيا بينما تضمن روسيا الوثيقه التي وقع
عليها النظام السوري ويجب على ايران ان
تمارس نفوذها بشكل ايجابي وخصوصا على حزب
الله والفصائل الشيعيه والنظام اذ ان
ايران كانت وعدت في موسكو بالقيام بذلك
وشاركت في الوثيقه
المشتركه اعود الى الدكتوره فاطمه الماضي
في الاستديو دكتوره فاطمه هل تتوقعين من
ايران ان تستجيب لهذا الطلب المتعلق
بالميليشيات نعم لا اظن بدون يعني هذا
يتعلق او يرتبط بشكل اساسي بالمفاوضات
اللاحقه يعني هل ستضمن ايران مصالحها في
سوريا ام لا عندما نتحدث عن الميليشيات
فهو استثمار ايران الحقيقي يعني في في
المنطقه ليس في في سوريا فقط وانما في
المنطقه حتى يعني اتذكر قبل فتره قصيره
كان مرشد الثوره الاسلام لم يتحدث عن
الحشد الشعبي انه يعني الثروه اليوم وغدا
عندما نقول غدا فهذا ينطبق ايضا على
الميليشيات الاخرى هذا الاستثمار على
الارض والذي احدث لايران هذا النفوذ لا
يمكن ان تتنازل عنه ايران بسهوله ط ام
انطلاقا من ذلك سيد قربانوف هل تتوقع ان
تضغط روسيا فعليا على ايران من اجل
الالتزام بشكل كامل اييه بوقف اطلاق النار
وفي مرحله اخرى بناء على تطورات التفاوض
ان
تسحب الميليشيات من
سوريا كما تعلمون اننا جميعا نعلم بان
ايران في هذا المثلث بين انقره طهران
وموسكو مدعوه لهذه المفاوضات لتكون ضامنه
لتنفيذ وقف اطلاق النار من جانب المليشيات
الشيعيه وان هذا الدور لايران هو امر
مقبول من روسيا ومن
تركيا
ولكن فيما يتعلق باستمرار هذا النزاع فلقد
شاهدنا سابقا انه كانت هناك بعض التناقضات
بين موسكو وطهران وبين دمشق وموسكو ايضا
وفي شهر اذار مارس من هذه
السنه حاول الكرملين ان يقلل
عدد القوات الروسيه في سوريا ليبين لتبين
وانها غاضبه او غير راضيه ازاء السلوك
الذي تنتهجه دمشق واعتقد ان هذه التناقضات
بين ايران وروسيا وبين دمشق وموسكو
سوف تظهر ل السطح مره اخرى في المراحل
الاخرى من هذا النزاع
واعتقد ان موسكو سيكون
عليها ان تضع بعض الضغوط على طهران لذلك ل
لتطبيق نقاط هذه
الاتفاقيه
وضمان عدم مشاركه المش الشيعيه في
استمراريه النزاع والقتال شكرا لك رسلان
كوربوف المحلل السياسي حدثنا من اسطنبول
واشكر الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي كبيره في
الشؤون الايرانيه شاركتنا هنا في
الاستوديو مشاهدينا الان ننتقل الى الملف
الثالث والاخير حيث تبحث ازدهار شعشاعه في
ابعاد الاعلان عن انطلاق مرحله ثانيه من
عمليات استعاده الموصل من تنظيم الدوله
بدعم من طيران التحالف الدولي ماذا حققت
المرحله الاولى من تلك العمليات